monsieur b tun c'est un espèce de
patriarche qui règne sur une famille
juive pied-noir à paris à belleville qui
a fait une grande réussite va
d'itinéraires social comme on dit et
mais simplement là où le bât blesse
c'est que son itinéraire sociale et sa
réussite s'est faite dans les formes
d'activités bon que la morale réponse ne
s'est pas le principal intérêt du film
intérêt du film je crois que c'est un
c'est une réflexion si vous voulez sur
l'intégration de certaines familles et
qui trouve dans la marginalité le moyen
de survivre par des procédés bien qu'on
peut
auquel on peut ont préféré d'autres
voilà en conclusion roger a nice nous
pensais pas que ce genre de film
continua à préserver cette sorte
d'identité pieds noirs qui dont vous
êtes jeu nous sommes peut-être là la
dernière génération je l'espère bien
j'espère même qu'on sera pas la dernière
génération quelquefois je me souviens un
ami me disait c'est formidable parce que
vous avez remplacé les marseillais les
marsillon sont arrivés à paris avec
pagnol fernandel rémur élise moby
charpin on va tous la grande équipe des
marseillais on m'a dit perry midi mathis
enfin tous toutes ces grandes grandes
grandes figures des institutions pour
les signifie que nous sommes et je dis
peut-être que qu'on va remplacer les
marseille à paris à la condition que que
veulent on trouve des auteurs pour
perpétuer cette et puis il ya l'accent
par exemple mais je crois que c'est vrai
que les enfants même né à marseille où
naît à paris continuent à voir que cet
accent pieds-noirs et publicis et
passionnante que son accent une question
de vie de musique de deux façons
s'exprimer de comportement de vitalité
d'entousiasme de façon de rire d'un
grand appétit comme ça qu'on a et c'est
ça qui donne une espèce de culture pieds
noirs